Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
And welcome back to Resident Evil 7.
Now I thought I was done with this for now, but
as many of you know, I am a man of persistence.
And I have a head bigger than my ego.
And I know...
-that I can beat this, and I have a good strategy for it
I was already doing it in the last video
But I just wanna beat this because by all accounts, everybody is saying that this is the hardest challenge in the game
If not for the sheer memorisation of it, and the trial and error
But it actually legitimately is hard because at the end of this, you have to fight a boss fight
With only being able to take one or two hits depending on how you get hit...
And all culminating in an area where you have no resources and nothing to your name
So I wanna beat it. So I'm gonna give this a few more tries,
even though I know for a fact that I've been having a lot of problems with this,
but I now know what boxes are bombs, I now know where the traps are
So long as I'm not stupid, and don't rush things...
I will be able to do this.
There's no reason that I can't do this.
FRUU- Goooood dammiiiit!
FUUUCKING COooock....
Alright we're gonna pull a mulligan on that one.
I didn't get good drops in the beginning anyway, so...
...Might as well try again
AUGH-
*Ethan death scream*
*Depressed sigh*
See, remember how I said at the top of this: "So long as I'm not stupid"? Well...
Ha- I should've known better!
I should've known that I am just... full o' beans.
Full of st-
Alright, I'm gonna blow that up. I bet that's gonna cause me problems later.
Alright, now I've made progress! So, dodge this trap-
Baaadunk.
Okay.
Then you just go up here, and to do this one you don't even need to waste a bullet-
You just need to stand over the trap and then jump down the hole
It works out really well. For some reason that one lasts longer because it's designed that way
All these fuckin' traps.
Alright so literally you just gotta...
Badoosh
then drop.
There you go.
Boooom!
All done.
Then go up.
We're back up.
Okay.
I'm gonna open this. Anything in here? I don't think there's ever anything in here.
It doesn't like to have anything in here for some reason.
And then...
Sca-doosh over here.
Check over in this corner for a box.
Okay. So I did blow up the one by the door, right?
I didn't forget about that one; I did blow that one up.
So then everything else...
*turret fire*
*body hitting the floor*
...can actually be taken out by this  uh... machine gun here.
And it's really convienent
because that helps me a lot.
cuz everything will just automatically die when they come charging for me.
NO! Protect me!
Protect me sooner than that, asshole
Yay, its dead.
Oh shit, ahhh
do not...do not, do not.
Big guy you're going down.
Your'e not big guy.
Alright, c'mon.
Oh, you're gonna play that game..
Fuck you.
God damn it. Do not.
Do not, do not, do not.
There we go.
Got him down.
*harsh sigh*
So what we're gonna have is, we're gonna have people crawling down. But what I didn't do
last time is I didn't actually set off
the bombs when I needed
to set off the bombs when I crawled under.
To save me quite a bit of....
ammo
Come on.
One down.
Wanna play?
Wanna play bubba?
Come on.
*very quietly* Come on. Come on.
Little further. Come on.
Crawl for it. You want it. I know ya want it.
Alright there we go.
Okay, so they're done.
So now I got the two crawly bastards around the corner.
*let's out breath of concentration*
Woah, okay. Running running running running. Do not, do not.
Do not. That was too close.
There we go. Dead for you.
Those guys are my worst nightmare
every time. Hate 'em hate 'em hate 'em.
Hate 'em, hate 'em!!
But we've officially made it a little farther than we did before
I just gotta keep an eye out for traps.
I've already taken care of the thing behind that door.
So I know that's not gonna kill me.
And then
we should be good.
To go out right?
Yeeeh
Yeah, I know I unlocked it. I didn't...
*quietly* Gonna, I'm gonna...
Yeesh! Okay
So I definitely got that. That
would have blown me
to smitheroons
Okay, I'm pretty sure now that
the traps are placed it should be
just straight shot out, right?
that's not right
That sounds bad
Can I j- Oohhh do not lag now.
Can you close that, okay
Anything out here?
Anything out here that wants to kill me?
*sigh of hardship*
Probably everything?
Let me just double check the area...to make sure...
*quietly* And that guy's still being creepy...
So we've officially made it farther than we ever have before.
I've still got the problem of Marguerite.
Also-
*creepy breathing sounds*
The fuck is that?
Shit. Ok.
That's why there are bombs there
Oh shit
Oh god. Woah hey, hey you
You came outta nowhere
Boosh
Oh boy...I hope I got it
I was wondering why those bombs were there.
wooh....
Ok. Well that's a lot of you
guys that wasted a ton of my ammo
Son of a bitch
A fuck
Of course I missed
Alright, just burn a little more maybe?
Woo, okaaaayyyyy no
Ok, he's dead
Yup. Ok. Dead dead dead
Dead as dead
Dead as dead can be
O no no no no I hear that
I hear that. I hear that you
scampering little bastards. Where are you?
Give me a clearing. Give me a god damn clearing
No
O boy O boy O boy
No no no did I get you?
*creature growls*
Okay...
I'm just...
I have to replace it with...O god damn it.
Not gonna risk it- Oh fuck off!
*whispers* Fuck you
Fuck you dude.
Fuck off so hard with your fucking bullshit
Is that all of em?
Sounds like it might of been all of em
What was that?
Okay, so are we done with the bullshit?!
Finally
Jesus Christ
Alright. I've walked through here before
There weren't any...
there weren't any things getting in my way
so there better not be any now!
Kay
Well, alright we've made it this far...
*sigh of exasperation*
Ok, so hopefully
there's gonna be some restocking happening here.
Okay
One box. I'll take it.
Lookin' for traps.
Two box. I'll take it.
*sarcastic* Psychostimulants, great.
What is that gonna do me? I'll just take em
to see if there's any under the area
Okay, there's some stuff down there
*sigh of slight disappointment*
Another shot gun. Great exactly what I needed
Alright whatever. Well this is
dead now so I'm just gonna get rid
of this
Okay...
Jesus...alright.
So there's one thing down there that I can see.
I can only imagine that as soon as I drop
down and I'm gonna look before I drop for
any bambs.
Fuckin' stupid bambs
And Marguerite's down there
That's what I assume
That's what I assume. Just assuming
I see that
Okay...
Okay
Strong first aid's not gonna do me much
good if I die in one hit
Okay
Just clearing these out cause
I don't wanna deal with em
Ok
I'm pretty sure Marguerite starts when
you go up the stairs, right?
That's the whole deal
Ooohhoho, saw you
Oh shit
Jesus...
That wouldn't have done much for me but...
I don't know...don't wanna risk it
*sarcasm* Great psychostimulants. Exactly what I need.
My favorite thing.
Alright...
So...
This is it! This is now or never. This is uh...
This is aaalll the beanz-
Okay, alright, here we go...
I got you
Ah, right in your stupid face
Ok so I've got to get
to a clearing.
Oh shit
Ok that's interesting to know
Ok where is she?
That's the question.
So there's turret in there
I just gotta know where she is
so I don't get...sprung
Oh boy...
Well now I'm afraid to move
*slimy sounds*
Uh oh
Ah!
Oh boy, okay, movin'!
Ok alright
Let me just trigger this
Ok where ya at?
Ohp! there's your crotch
Oh boy
Alright
*Marguerite laughs*
Okay, alright, okay, whatever you say
Alright...
So... there is a
turret in there
Which I might be able to use to my advantage but
I'm not 100% sure about that
There you are
*Marguerite cries out*
Ah it would
Ok I got flamerthrower that's all I got
basically
Okay - oh boy...
Don't like that
Well I'm officially out of ammo
aahahaha, that's fun
Greeaat, okay....
*very quietly* Oh boy...
Where you gone?
Well that's- that's not what I wanted
Oh boy
Ok what did I just get?
Ooh boy
Ow ow ow! Where the fuck
did that come from?!
Ooooh
that's a thing!
Get that
Fuck
Open it up
What is that? What is that? What is that?
You the hands gun ammo?
maybe
*Marguerite laughs*
Where are you coming from?
Ooh, she triggered a bamb
Oh boy
She's gettin' shot
OH! Okay. hello!
Woah, okay, gotta move, gotta move
gotta move, gotta move- Woah!
NO!
God damn it! Are you fucking kidding me?
O god.
I'm alive apparently
Don't know how
Oh god.
O god. Okay, this is good
Hoh, boy
Why are these still here?
Oh boy...
That was fuckin' ridiculous
I can not believe I survived that
Where are you?
Where is she?
*sigh of near-death experience*
So if I can dance around this turret
that actually benefits me
a lot
Just gonna keep an eye out
Where's sh- oooh!
Fuck.
Thought i heard her
oh boy
hoh boy
Where is she?
Okay...
Show me dat ass!
Alright...
She's a little sloooowwoo!
Alright then
That's weird
What's she doing?
Her path finding is all over the place
Aye aye aye, no thank you
Woah
Hello?
Okay, then
Okay
Well took a couple pot shots at her crotch
Wooh!
That was a good ol' thump but I am completely
out of ammo--wooh!
Okay, she's on the way
Okay Gotta move gotta move gotta move
upstairs
Okay...I don't think there's any items left
in the house so I'm just gonna have to try to...
Ooh, there might be one more unless that's
not an item
Unless it's a trap
She in there?
Eeh! Don't like that!
Ok where is she?
Alright, she's- ooh
Ok then. Alright, well, I'm just gonna you know...
go down this way again
Woh boy
God damn it. It's not gonna take any shots at her.
The only problem is I just don't see where--
Oh, I see where it is now okay
Woo, she's coming right behind isn't she?
Ooh, she's right behind me
Ooh boy!
Hoh boy
Aye aye aye aye!!
Eee- Ok got some on her
Woah! Hey! Did I do it?
HEEEEY!!
OH MY GOD!
HOOOLY SHIIIT!
HOOLY SHIIT! I DID IT!
Right down to my last bullet...
I only had a knife to my name!
HOOLY SHIT!
I DID IT!
YEEEEAAH!
Ok
ohhh damn
I did it.
What I don't get a reward for that?!
JESUS.
That was insanity.
Man I was sweatin' bullets that whole time
So I...I guess that's it.
Ui ughh . I guess that's it.
Cause
Man...
That was crazy!
I might, on my own, I might play the whole
game on the hardest difficulty
because I've heard that there's, uh...
Ohh man I heard there's a mad house difficulty
that uh is just a complete and utter
nightmare to get through.
Anyway, so, I'm still just like adrenaline
is pumping me so...
AAGH, anyway! So that is
it for Resident Evil 7
for now. :(
There is more DLC coming, but it's not coming
until the spring. So if it does
come and when it does come, I wanna
keep playing this
Resident Evil 7 is really,special to me
not special to me like "oh it makes me feel
butterflies in my stomach". I'm saying
it feels special because
it feels good
The feel of the game is good. The movement is good
the shooting is good. The action is good.
The...the the..environment is good
so that it leads you into like this nervous
like tense situation where
you're always running out of everything that you need
and anything can kill you at any moment
It adds that element where, in, like,
Amnesia, and Slender, and Five Nights at Freddy's
You don't have any defense.
But in this one it balances the lines
so well between having
defense and still being helpless
like it's...it walks that line
very well and I love it for that
I really really enjoy this game
A LOT. It's not perfect by any
means but god if they continue with
this aspect for all the games
they've got an amazing
amazing series waiting for them
Now whether or not the DLC was worth all the money
because one volume cost ten bucks
one volume cost 25 bucks Oh!
Woops! That's half the cost of the actual game.
I don't know if this qualifies but it does add
some replayability to it.
And I like that a lot
They did some good stuff here. They should...
Ya know, credit is given where
credit is due and I'm not one to suck ass of any
game company but...
this is pretty good. I like it a lot.
So, Thank ya everybudy so much for watching. I will
see you in the spring with this game
again once that DLC is released.
So thanks again and
as always I will see YOU
in the next video! Buh bye!